[Inaudible] uh, Don
[inaudible] law hardships.
[Inaudible].
Varda and chancellor of
[inaudible].
Yeah, [inaudible] new Gloria.
What were the fresh to do?
Uh, uh, [inaudible] from
[inaudible]. So
[inaudible] helped me narrow shadow.
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] con this new, uh, new, uh,
[inaudible] uh, toy and tested for
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] I suppose to us probably. Um, so thank God.
[inaudible] um, Ms. Carol. [inaudible]. Yeah.
[Inaudible].
Yeah, no, it's good to see you.
[inaudible] Yeah.
[inaudible].
Oh, yeah. Or
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] me knew the door though.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
And you just gave it to him, Booksmith it. Uh
[inaudible] uh, there are some odd, uh, intersect. Uh,
I just gave you done hot, Ian Alden. Some you,
uh, [inaudible] do I
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] Oh, man,
you got me to hide in the mission lips. Oh,
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
No, we [inaudible] be able to spec like
[inaudible] man, man. Uh
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] example,
[inaudible] both
Festa tiling sneer with empty tour shoulder
52. So [inaudible].
[Inaudible] yo.
Yeah. Mandate. [inaudible] truly
[inaudible] [inaudible] okay.
[inaudible] we'll do a
[inaudible] so they don't develop, make a poor man
[inaudible] podium.
That's it. Do, do you take it out?
[inaudible] uh, golden
[inaudible] dry there.
Oh, absolute
[inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] uh [inaudible] um,
Oh, uh, some
[inaudible] let's some, all lipoma
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] or, um,
[inaudible] throw the
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] ministry. Yeah.
So, uh, but uh, held up to him. Okay. Okay. Take the flight.
Yeah. Yeah, sure.
How are you enjoying doing this? Oh,
it's different, but yeah. You know, you should try things. Yeah. Yeah.
That's how I feel. Okay. I'll we set?
[inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Don't we don't tell him just to eat a little
[inaudible] [inaudible].
Yeah.
[inaudible] the big unit to spore
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] um, Dom bestest forum for the,
of felt [inaudible] or some core murder. Uh,
[inaudible] a lot, some evoke not plea interview, but, uh,
[inaudible] at guru and [inaudible] would cast on the
[inaudible] for robots for so, uh,
mammo scope and atmospheric the most
[inaudible] do a bleeds for him better.
[Inaudible] uh, uh,
[inaudible]. [inaudible].
Let's come on air. Yeah, no man.
[Inaudible].
No Medula shirt taller for in public
[inaudible] uh, so I had hobbies.
[Inaudible] hate to be all Brit, uh,
um,
[inaudible] um, I'll
[inaudible] some hetero Roberto
[inaudible] [inaudible] Oh, [inaudible]
Oh, I'll turn the by the tablet. Oh, well there are some, uh,
I lit some fruit. I know
[inaudible] well are, uh,
Or yeah, take the [inaudible]. Uh,
yeah, I take the [inaudible].
There are some [inaudible] they can go from
[inaudible].
David. See you in South Philly. Killing it out in the secretary.
Uh, the, uh, the whole interference.
[Inaudible] yeah, yeah, yeah.
[inaudible] eh, I'll put it
[inaudible] uh, then Donald, I don't mean only, um,
conduit, conduit door folks. Some see it, the dog
[inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] so four months Stella floorboard.
[inaudible] tell them and set dirtied.
So Armenia foreign head for it that
[inaudible] now a starter home. Sit, leave your new yarns,
staying [inaudible] or
[inaudible] or
[inaudible] whose value or believe its value. They will say
[inaudible] Fernando Lander. [inaudible] Nara, Finland.
[inaudible] Iran, Iraq, Afghanistan. [inaudible] men.
[inaudible] don't call me in on coma plots or don't bleed in DL will be gear
it's value. We'll do it for check this out.
Demand for CFPB the quarter. We'll see the longer
[inaudible] before King [inaudible] alarm had
[inaudible] or somebody
[inaudible] or [inaudible] yet to blow.
And the most [inaudible] for me to live with [inaudible] we'll do it.
[inaudible] the convener have a microphone COVID heat.
[Inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] support the nest. Uh, then
[inaudible] say I do it.
[inaudible].
Let me
[inaudible] okay. [inaudible] okay.
Down millions of XL, extremist
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible] Scott Blondess
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] no audio door.
Uh
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] um, um,
[inaudible] uh, thank felon. Direct or feel mother or
[inaudible] score. [inaudible] uh,
hello?
[inaudible] fantastic.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
Yeah, man. Do I love front desk?
[inaudible].